make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are a little behind on
absolute carnage and you would think
that we would be caught up right like
you think we would have it all caught up
and everything because I really love
this event but I took a vacation all
last week except for like two days and
one of those audios was already just
kind of out there so now we're actually
getting back into the thick of things
but I actually getting back into the
meat potatoes of recording a lot of the
guys are probably also wondering why I
haven't done full story videos recently
I'm actually saving them towards the end
of the year and I'm just gonna kind of
like do a month where I just dump a
whole bunch of full story videos from
what we've done so far and just kind of
go from there right so absolute carnage
will probably come out in like November
and it'll be like a few others here and
there so yes absolute carnage part two
okay so what Donnie Cates is basically
written so far is this story where
things are in dire straits right I mean
and here's a funny thing about absolute
carnage is in this issue and this this
really technically it's a second issue
although it's like the fourth part more
or less it almost kind of feels like
spider-verse
meets like carnage I mean we're not
dealing with multiversal versions of
carnage but it does feel like that and
so far as anybody who's ever held a
symbiote is basically being tracked down
by carnage and being consumed now this
is one of the things that I kind of
wanted to toy with in the last video and
we kind of want to bring to light in
this one is that really Norman Osborn is
not fully under the control of carnage
right and it's something that a few of
you guys pointed out in the last in the
comments of last video for those
individuals who were totally under the
control of carnage they have that little
spinning us you know spiral thing on
their face for Norman Osborn he doesn't
have that now why he doesn't have that
is not explicitly given to us right
because looking at this author of the
top of our heads what we've seen so far
those individuals who carnage has
consumed are under his control right but
the individuals that we see them consume
so far at least in the first few issues
have just been those these basically
taken a portion of himself and put it
inside of them so we don't really know
at least at the moment at least the time
I'm making this video anyway like
suspend your disbelief for a for a
second but the idea behind this is that
it doesn't look like Norman Osborn is
totally under the control of carnage and
this is cool because it allows Norman
Osborn to basically maintain himself or
it allows him to kind of keep the
personality that we've all kind of come
to know and love over the years the kind
of rebellious guy the guy that like you
can't tell me what to do because what
you basically have here by virtue of
Cletus Kasady and carnage is you've got
two roosters in the hen house that's
essentially what's going on and one of
them's gonna have to go that's basically
what's taking place here now of course
for spider-man and venom fighting off
against these mass
numbers of carnage forces there's no way
they can win right and it would be a
foolish measure to try and stay it would
be stupid I mean there's there really
wouldn't be any sense in it right
they're throwing away their life for
something dumb if they were to stay here
now remember spider-man does not know
all the changes that have gone on with
the venom semi he doesn't know
everything that's happened here and so
this is important because for any Brock
himself of course having come into
contact with null basically sort of
expanded the powers of his symbiote
which in turn granted him of course the
power of flight by use of wings
spider-man doesn't know all this stuff
right so he's kind of coming into this
thinking this is venom as I've always
known him we're standing at the top of
like you know Ravencroft asylum if we
jump off we're probably gonna be dashed
to pieces on the rocks we're screwed
we're basically gonna die and and it's
cool because Eddie Brock basically flies
them to safety now this is where the
Norman Osborn part begins to come in
because where you have you know Norman
odds weren't asking the question why are
we going after them the response he's
being given by it by Cletus Kasady is
well because there's other people for us
to go after now this is kind of a cool
thing because Norman Osborn stance is
what we got to take out spider-man and
we got to take out venom because they'll
come back and they'll they'll catch us
later on and in reality he's not wrong
the funny thing about this is that
they're actually looking at the same
goal from two different perspectives
right so like Norman Osborn is looking
at this from the from the perspective of
like what we saw with Dark Reign take
out the heroes right off the bat like
give them out of there as fast as you
can and there'll be nobody staying
nobody to stand against you Cletus
Kasady on the other hand seems a little
more subversive right his stance is we
won't go after them we'll just amass our
forces - such a huge amount that we
don't need to worry about them right
it's like when they come calling with
whatever forces they have it won't make
a difference
it's cool in terms of how their
approaches work because both of them
have merit now the problem with this
comes when it's venom and and Spider Man
kind of transitioning back to these
characters again what is venom in Spider
Man and it's what do we do next right
like where do we go from here because
they're both in pretty dire straits
right I mean this is basically their
worst nightmare right in a lot of
different ways it's the worst thing they
could have seen happening the most
insane character they've ever come
across bond it's one of the most
powerful symbionts in existence probably
the most powerful short of of nolza
symbiote God himself is now running amok
in the city of New York and marshalling
his forces it's pretty bad that's this
it's pretty terrible you're talking
about a crazy guy so he's leading the
show he's running the show here and then
he's creating a whole mess of people
like a whole army of people who can
avoid spider-man's spider-sense it's the
most horrifying thing ever
because at any point spider-man could
die and he'd be dead before he heard the
sound of killed him so it's one of these
crazy scenarios now for Eddie Brock
himself things are a little bit
different the cool aspect is that
because of the fact that this is really
what Donnie Cates seemed to be it seems
to be going with it he can kind of go to
different directions right but venom
himself can kind of feel the forces of
of carnage it doesn't mean he knows he
can pinpoint them exactly where they are
right like he's no Molly Walker from
heroes but it's one of these things
where you can kind of feel you know feel
the fact that they're out there and
they're kind of making their way towards
him so and almost kind of seems to be an
empathic thing how it is that he picks
up on that again it can kind of go a
couple different ways it can go by way
of the fact that all these forces are
being marshaled by a Grendel symbiote
which is kind of a precursor to the the
symbian of Eddie Brock and have like the
Venom's to be and all that kind of stuff
we can kind of go that route or we can
go the route that I think is a little
more interesting is that basically
carnage is spawned directly from venom
and so because carnage is spawned
directly from venom and because carnage
bonded with cletus kasady on the blood
level even though he's using a Grindle
symbiote it kind of seems to carry over
and it allows Eddie Brock to basically
feel the offspring of Cletus Kasady in
the form of all these different forces
out there so it's kind of a cool little
moment here but ultimately they end up
settling on the idea that spider-man is
essentially going to marshal the
Avengers right because remember
spider-man is an Avenger and he has been
since the New Avengers by Brian Michael
Bendis it's one of the things a lot of
people tend to forget that spider-man is
kind of easy he's out there and he does
his own superhero thing but unless
you're reading an Avengers story that
involves him being part of the team it's
easy to forget that he is a member of
the team the issue with the Avengers
comics as you usually see them is that
they often focus on the core Avengers
rosters right the ones who were there
day in and day out now again it's kind
of a cool little show by Donna Cates
because in this day and age and the age
of crossovers with Marvel it's the one
question a lot of people would ask is
like why didn't spider-man get a hold of
the Avengers right so he nips that right
in the butt like we'll call Captain
America will call Wolverine those two
guys specifically because they dealt
with a Grendel symbian in the past and
they kind of know how to defeat them or
at least have a much better
understanding of how to face off against
it the problem is that in the middle of
all this suddenly Eddie Brock basically
gets a call from from the maker Reed
Richards from the Ultimate Universe now
the idea here is that read this this
version of read the maker has come just
been safeguarding Dillon right the son
of Eddie Brock albeit Dillon doesn't
know and so one of the funny things is
that he you know literally the maker
says I've been combing through the FBI's
database here and like an weighing was
not in the body and like them
ass grave that was dug up right like she
was her herb her corpse was never there
and that was a big concern of Eddie
Brock because remember we talked about
this in the last video but an weighing
was basically his ex-wife more or less
right I mean you know it was one of
these things where Donnie Cates kind of
kind of threw it in there so that she
was pregnant with Eddie's child and just
we never knew ah but it was is one of
those things where basically she was the
Venom symbiote for a little while and
then eventually I drove her crazy Eddie
Brock drove her crazy a whole bunch of
things drove her insane and she jumped
off a building into her death right like
in between that time period that's when
Donnie Cates came in and said actually
she was pregnant with Eddie Rock kid and
the result is I did that kid is here now
the issue with this is that if and
weighing having been a host for the
venom semion at one point did not have a
codex in her body and the question is
who has it and what the maker says is
she passed it off to Dillon now this is
a very important thing because what this
means is that a codex can leave a person
and go to someone else in reality this
is a way out for Donnie Cates because
what he could do here is at the end of
the story he could basically say all the
codex all the codices are now inside
carnage and where carnage would seek to
rule as the right hand of Nova symbian
and kind of bring darkness to the
universe nor would kind of be like now
and then just kill Cletus Kasady take
take everything and take although the
codices to himself and then boy
everybody probably end up dying anyway
because he would be returned to full
power but the fact remains that codex
can be passed from one person to the
next now we don't know if the codex is a
physical thing but we know it's written
into a person's DNA but as we know when
it comes to offspring it's not like a
mom gives birth to a child and then all
her blood goes into the child and all
her DNA goes into the child and she
loses everything about herself it's more
let's just kind of copying her DNA and
the father's DNA into that baby and
there's kind of a combination of both
and so this creates a really interesting
scenario here because normally you would
look at that you would say well the
codex is kind of copied from her into
into Dylan but instead it just went into
Dylan entirely so it's kind of a cool
little revelation here I mean there's a
lot you can extrapolate from these small
little things and that's why I Donnie
Cates is such a great writer because you
can bring these small little bits and
pieces into this stuff and just kind of
throw it in there now from here of
course you basically deal with Eddie
Brock facing off against like all these
carnage brindle guys who are all running
up on him it is like as fast as they can
it's kind of like a cool moment because
it's like the Venom's last stand and so
it's pretty badass I really dig this
because here's the thing here here's the
thing all right Donnie Cates is venom
it's cool because the way he writes it I
feel like Donnie Cage
writing venom is about the most awesome
he's been in a few decades and I say
that understanding what it is that I'm
saying right I mean he was basically
saying like venom hasn't really been
cool since lethal protector by David
McLean II and I would kind of agree with
that I mean there's been some cool
moments but venom himself being cool I
don't think is really happened for a
long time and I'm talking about like
when when things like scorpion when max
bargain was venom and stuff like that I
mean I guess maybe I guess fans of Flash
Thompson of agent venom will probably
get pissed off about that I don't really
care I never really liked agent venom
all that much I was never a huge fan of
him like he was cool and it was a cool
concept but I'm old-school Eddie Brock
all the way right like I dig Eddie Brock
it has been and so Eddie Brock is venom
hasn't really been that cool because he
hasn't really been venom for a long time
but still the fact remains it's one of
these awesome little these little
moments because what it does is it
switches over to Miles Morales and to
scorpion right now again scorpion was a
previous host for a Venom symbiote which
means that he's basically got the Codex
inside of him right I mean you know Mac
Gargan being venom that came during Dark
Reign right he was one of the Dark
Avengers or at least one of the dart
guys out there right now the Dark
Avengers with all the villains playing
good guys essentially and so this was a
cool thing because you end up having
like like Miles Morales holding his own
against all these guys now this is an
important an important thing to talk
about here because for those individuals
who are new to Miles Morales they would
look at that and they would still see
him as like the new kid on the block and
a lot of ways he is in comparison like
how long Venom's been I've been active
at how long spider-man's been active and
how long Cletus Kasady has been active
he is kind of the new kid on the block
right even looking at like other spider
characters right like Miguel O'Hara
spider-man 2099 looking at like Cain
looking at Ben Reilly looking a lot of
those characters who were out there yeah
I mean they they've they've been there
and and they're there they've been there
for a very very long time so really
miles is the new kid but miles has a lot
of experience under his belt that really
helps him catch up right the entire
events of spider-verse
alright fighting off against the
inheritors it's my two versus two I mean
there's all these these cool moments
he's cool storylines that he's been a
part of where he's faced off against
some pretty heavy hitters so grabbing a
lot of experience rolling it under his
belt the entirety of Secret Wars by by
Jonathan Hickman all the events that
transpired in there so he's grown up
pretty fast and gained a pretty solid
understanding of what he's capable of
and so again using his his shock you
know all that kind of cool stuff facing
off against these guys he's able to hold
his own to a degree more than you would
expect which is kind of cool for a
little miles to go miles you got it
little buddy
but he's doing a great job but uh but of
course
that Gargan tries to escape envenom
forces and back in again the issue is
that as soon as that happens they're
basically met by by carnage who's like
okay cool
smash this guy up and drag him in and
I'm sorry bye-bye actually it looks like
Norman Osborn to be on he doesn't really
have the thing on his head but they're
basically end up snatching him up and of
course they managed to impale him but of
course he ends up getting away when
miles goes to attack and this is one of
the crappy things that goes on here
because what takes place is that where
this is revealed to be Cletus Kasady and
it is actually him going through and and
trying to capture Mac Gargan we end up
having him capture Miles Morales and
this is kind of a big moment because we
haven't really seen him capture a spider
character yet and so that's why it's
really seems to feel a lot like spider
verse because it kind of seems you
moving in the realm of the inheritors
the question that asked here is what
will Miles do in relation to beefing up
the power of like you know Carnage's
forces like will it kind of be spread
all throughout them or we'll just beef
up the powerful eaters Cassidy how's all
this going to work
oh the other thing to bear in mind here
is that there's a lot of information the
miles has a lot of places to get to
right like the the what is it the the
spider the spider folks out there the
what was the multiversal spider-man team
I don't know what they were called
nobody read it so Marvel canceled it but
uh I guess I'm not alone in that regard
but but nonetheless there's a lot of
cool things that could come out of this
a lot of information that could be
extrapolated and could be extracted by
Cletus Kasady from Miles Morales on how
to defeat these various characters on
how to take all of them out as far as
I'm aware miles does not know that Eddie
Brock has a son Dillon and so as far as
were aware I mean I know that the
carnage kind of knows but there's
nothing to lead carnage to know that
that Dillon is one with the Codex right
I mean we don't really know that yet I
mean I guess he's just kind of tracking
down inherently but still it's a cool
moment right I mean because what this
does is he goes into the one shot of
Miles Morales being taken over by
carnage is a cool moment like it's the
story's pretty solid like I'm really
digging it so far but if you guys are
new here to comment explain it make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the rob for if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]